(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the question
if you were a boat,
what type of boat would you be?
- And this might strike
you as an odd question,
maybe you've thought about this before.
We actually got--
- I've never thought about it.
- We got this question
from Mr. Alex Punch,
who has moved onto
bigger and better things.
Still remains good friends,
he actually stopped by today.
He didn't tell me he was gonna be here.
- Mythical crew member emeritus.
- Yeah, so--
- Let's call him that so
we're happy for Alex as
he had a great opportunity
working for somebody. (scoffs)
It's not me so I, once he
told me he had an opportunity
and we heard about the
specifics, I was like,
oh yeah, okay man.
I don't remember.
I'm not gonna promote his company.
- Well we wish him well, we wish him well.
- We wish him well, we love him.
- And we're using one of
his ideas for this podcast.
He actually, this is an idea
that he actually pitched
for an Ear Biscuit.
He said that his mother
was a child therapist.
- He said counselor I
think, maybe therapist too.
- Yeah, something along those lines.
And this is a question
that she gets the children
that she works with to ask and answer.
- And if we've proven anything,
if something's good enough for children,
it's good enough for us.
- For man children?
- Yeah.
- Good enough for children,
good enough for man children.
- So really this was, I
mean it was basically,
it was an idea conceived by Alex's mom,
along with Alex conceived
by his mom by the way.
- It's probably in some
sort of book or something
that she studied.
- Well.
- You think she came up with it?
Let's credit it.
- Let's just say we came up with it.
Let's cut everything we've just said.
- Okay all right, we came
up with this question.
- We got this idea that
we think will be good
for child counselors and therapists,
what kind of boat would
you be if you could be
but because it gives insight
into how you view your own--
- Self.
- Self, your personhood,
your personality.
- And we're gonna answer
the question for each other.
- We'll get into that.
- We're gonna answer
the question for each other as well.
We're gonna guess which boat,
I'm not trying to guess which boat
you described yourself as,
I'm just describing, my thought
was to describe what boat
I thought you were and
you may or may not agree.
Then you can tell me what
boat you are and vice versa.
- I know what boat I think I am
and I know what boat I think you are
which I incidentally think is the boat
that you think you are.
- And I would be, but we are gonna talk
about the different types of boats
and so my answers may change,
but as it stands right now,
just with my limited knowledge
of boats coming into this,
I'm not a boat master.
I like to think of myself as a waterman,
but I've only been in a few boats.
- What is a waterman?
- It's just a man of the water.
- And you think of yourself that way?
You think of yourself
as a man of the water?
- Yeah like my heritage, you know, those--
- Oh.
- The Scots up on the lochs.
You know, crossing the lochs
and swimming and boating
and Vikings, pillaging villages.
- I get it.
- But not really doing that personally
'cause I get a little seasick, you know.
- I think of myself as a soilman.
- Yeah.
- Like a man of the soil.
- And I think that your last name,
we've talked about this at some point,
I think that your name
Neal means to like kneel
and plant a seed. (chuckles)
- It doesn't.
- A man who kneels.
- I don't know what it means
but that ain't it.
- And caresses the soil.
I think it's a farming thing,
I do think it is a farming thing.
- Yeah.
- You know a man of the
soil, a man of the water.
Water's gotta have soil,
it's always gotta have water,
so you have mud.
That's why we're the muddy boys.
- We're the muddied boys, okay so we're--
- No not muddied boys,
it's the muddy boys.
- But we should talk about yesterday
'cause yesterday was
technically a work day, yet--
- Speaking of child therapy.
- We didn't, took advantage of,
took advantage of time that we rarely have
to not come into the
office and also red alert,
not really work that much.
Last, like coming back
from Thanksgiving break,
I looked at the whole
calendar year for 2019
and I was like, I wanna go
ahead and put all the stuff
on the calendar that we know about,
like we're doing a lot of touring stuff,
we're shooting a lot of GMM of course.
I wanna know every day in 2019
that we're shooting anything
and obligated to stuff and
I wanna put blackout dates,
like the credit card
companies do or Disney does
when you buy an annual pass.
- Right.
- So Jenna and I
worked very hard on this calendar.
- Oh so that blacked out
Monday was months old?
- That's Thanksgiving of last year, yeah.
- Oh wow.
- I guess I didn't tell you.
- You didn't tell me
'cause it was Sunday night,
my wife was with you and Christy--
- I was hanging out
with, yeah, with Jessie,
she was hanging out with us.
- She said,
"Are you working tomorrow?"
I was like, "Yeah."
And she's like, "Well Link's not."
- And she was with me and she was like,
I was like listen, please don't--
- You gotta tell me these things.
- Don't put me in the middle of this.
It's on the calendar.
- Yeah but it's--
- It's on the special
Link and Jenna calendar--
- But it's a Monday--
- That you were invited to.
- It's a Monday though, see I mean--
- Yeah but after tour, I'm, anyway--
- No I'm glad, I'm glad I didn't come in.
- 'Cause watch out
buying that annual pass.
Look at the blackout dates first.
- You show up to Disney and you're like--
- And they turn you away.
- What, no.
- You have to pay, you have
to drop 1,000 quid to get in there.
- So we had a day with our,
I mean I had a day with
Shepherd, my youngest.
You had a day with--
- Well me and Christy hung out
and then--
- Your middle.
- Well I mean Christy
and I were gonna hang out
and do some stuff and the
mail had really piled up,
but then Lily was sick.
She called and had to
come home from school.
I was like well, now you gotta go get her
and now I gotta figure
this out and I gotta,
I'm gonna do a little bit of work.
But then I picked up Lando
and then I picked up Lincoln
from school, it's just like
whoa, that just feels great
to pick up a kid from school,
feels like I'm dadding so hard.
Look at me drivin' up,
get in the car, kid.
I'm gonna be bangin' some Chicago.
Blastin' Chicago.
I'm not bangin' Chicago.
Sounds like I'm having
sex with the band Chicago.
- Yeah.
- Which I've never been given
that opportunity so I
can't say what I would do.
- Or the city of Chicago.
I'm sure there's a place,
there's an area you could find.
(laughs)
- Blasting (chuckles).
- Did you blast it for real?
- I blasted it, yes.
- So with the windows rolled down?
So you were trying to embarrass your kids?
- Not with the windows rolled down
but when he opened the door to
get in, it just spilled out,
Chicago just blew out like the windy city.
- And what, was there a--
(Link blows air)
Dad, Dad.
A quick shut of the door, was
there an embarrassment factor?
- Lincoln doesn't do that,
Lily's the one to do that
and Lando for totally different reasons.
I won't get into that but
they both have their reasons
but the middle child, he
just goes with the flow, man,
whatevs.
- Mm.
- And he gets in the car and he's like,
oh you got the bikes on the back.
I'm using your bike rack
a lot, thank you for that.
- Yeah you haven't brought it back.
- I keep using it.
Somebody's gotta use it.
- Well I would--
- I bought Lincoln
a mountain bike--
- Like to use it.
- Bought Link a, well just call me.
- (sputters) That's not how it works.
- Just call me if you need it.
I really need it.
- Bring it back to my house
and then, or get your own.
- Well, I already have yours.
I really didn't wanna talk about this
'cause I didn't want it
to come to this but--
- 'Cause you knew that it would.
- It's mine now.
- No it's not.
- That bike rack's mine.
It's, you made a good choice in buying it
'cause it works great--
- Yeah it's a good bike rack.
- So I like how it works.
- It's the best.
Highest rated.
- You should get another
one for your house.
- And then I'll sell it to you
for the price of a new one.
- I already have one.
- Yeah, you're gonna buy me a new one.
- So I actually bought myself a new bike
and I gave Lincoln my old bike
'cause I got a bigger one.
And--
- You got a new mountain bike?
- I did, yeah.
- When did this happen?
- I got a 29er.
When I borrowed the thing
from you like two months ago.
- You got shocks in the
front and back, dual?
- No, I only got 'em in the
front because my old bike,
which Lincoln was going
to ride is a hard tail
and I didn't want him looking at my bike
and have any excuse for why
he doesn't wanna ride with me.
- Oh, okay.
- So mine's a hard tail.
And so he's like oh you
got the bikes in the back?
I was like yeah remember I told
you I was gonna pick you up
from school, we're gonna go biking.
He knows, I can't tell
if Lincoln's into it yet
or if he knows that I'm
so into it that he's just
being very polite so he
doesn't put up a fight.
So we went and we were
bikin' on this single track
and it's, I picked something
that wasn't too ambitious.
'Cause I don't wanna burn him.
The thing is, the last
couple times we've been out
I've taken Lando too and
I was very delinquent
in teaching Lando to ride
a bike, like literally,
I taught him to ride a
bike three months ago.
He's nine years old.
- You're not gonna go
up and down any hills with that situation.
- But then that bike was
too small so then I had
to buy him a bike and
the only place in town
had these, they were like mountain bikes
and I was like, so he went
from learning to ride a bike
to a week later riding a mountain bike.
But he, that's the key.
Don't try to teach, parents out there,
don't try to teach your kids
at a young age to do anything.
Wait until they can basically
figure it out on their own
and then take all the credit.
- That's not good advice.
- My son learned how
to ride a bike in 10
minutes and two weeks later,
he was on a mountain bike
in the woods because of me.
Waiting until he was way too
old to learn how to do it.
That goes for reading, that goes for math,
that goes for--
- This is questionable on many levels.
- It goes for like relationships.
Don't have open
communication with your kids
about anything until
it's basically too late
and then you can take all
the credit for how they're--
- Screwing them up?
- Doing everything perfectly.
Yeah this is kinda fizzling out.
- Yeah.
- I'm a soil man, it's,
you know, it's different
for me than most people.
But I will say we get
out on the single track
and I was like Lincoln,
you go in front of me
that way you can set the pace,
I can keep an eye on you,
I can bark orders to you.
Like shift down, shift
up, like just coaching.
- Oh coaching you call it.
- You gotta learn how to
mountain bike from the back.
- Whew.
- If you're in the front
and you're yelling, you can't be heard,
'cause all of the sound
fires forward down the trail.
There's horses on this trail,
I wanted him to go first
in case he was gonna run up
in the tuchus of a horse.
'Cause that ain't gonna be me.
Get a handlebar in a horse tuchus?
- So is he, what kinda, we're not talking
going up and down a steep grade?
- A little bit, yeah.
- And he's fine with this.
- He's afraid.
What I was saying was I
took Lando out on this trail
a few days earlier.
I always get so ambitious
and I scare my kids off
and Lando's like basically
huffin' and puffin'
and breakin' down in tears and saying,
"Dad, you lied to me!
"You said this was gonna be flat!"
And I'm like, I'm like,
"Lando, you're right.
"I'm sorry.
"We can turn around right now."
I'm just trying to patch it up
because I don't wanna turn him off
from just my passion.
- Mountain biking is your passion?
- It was my passion, I lost it
and I'm trying to regain it.
- Okay.
- With my boys, with my children.
With Lily too but she's just not into it.
She's not up for it.
- Mm-hmm.
- So we had to turn around and I'm like,
Lincoln, we're gonna
come back just me and you
and we're gonna blaze
this trail without that,
the loser kid. (chuckles)
And all I mean by loser kid is
the one that we kept losing.
- Okay. (chuckles)
- I love him, he's not a
loser, but we kept losin' him
so doesn't that make him a loser?
That makes me a loser.
- On two levels.
- That's true.
So we went back and we're on this trail
and Lincoln's going ahead of
me and I just, I had a moment
that I was like, a
moment of dad gratitude,
da-gratitude and I was like,
this is a dream come true.
Like literally I'd
been, well not dreaming,
but I've been daydreaming
about this moment
where I'm like mountain
biking on a single track
with my own progeny.
- [Rhett] What specifically happened?
- Nothing, we just rode the bikes.
- Oh.
- It was special.
It was special.
- I thought like his,
like his helmet got in front
of the sun or something.
- You thought I was
building up to a story?
- (chuckles) Yeah.
(Link laughs)
- I thought something specific happened.
- That happened, man.
A moment of gratitude, like,
I mean just you and your
boy doing something.
- Yeah I had a crepe with my boy.
- You had a crepe?
(Rhett chuckles)
Did you have a da-gratitude
moment with a crepe?
- I had an excellent day
with Shepherd, I mean,
we really had a good time.
We got lunch together.
He has a crepe problem.
If there's a crepe on the
menu, he will order it.
- How's that a problem?
- Well I would say it's
a borderline addiction
to crepes.
- Oh wow.
- But there's a lot worse
things to be addicted to.
- Is he stealing money from
your wallet, you're like,
what are you doing?
You bust in the room and he's like--
- I learned it from you, Dad!
I saw you eat a thin pancake!
- I'm scrapin' together
scratch for a crepe!
- Well we split the crepe.
We each had a sandwich,
we split the crepe,
we're having a great discussion.
We've each got a--
- Were you in Paris?
- No, just, they serve crepes
at U.S. establishments.
- Oh cool.
- Although this was
a French bakery and then we went to a park
that has just all kinds of things going on
and so we each took a book
and I was like, "Shepherd,
do you have a book
"that you could read?"
Because it was a beautiful day,
we were gonna walk around--
- Beautiful day, wasn't it?
- We're gonna find a bench.
- Wasn't it a perfect day?
- Yeah and do some bench reading.
Screw mountain biking when
you can read on a bench.
- A bench is like a mountain bike--
- That doesn't move.
Can't get hurt on a bench.
- I can prove you wrong there.
- But so we go and we,
and Shepherd has in mind,
this is a large area and
there's all kinds of stuff
at this place and he has a
map and I'm letting him lead
and he's like, you know,
he's having a lot of fun.
And he's like, we need
to find a desolate bench.
I was like I'm on team desolate bench.
- He said desolate bench?
- I'm completely on board.
He said there's a lot of people--
- He's 11 years old right?
- 10, he's like--
- He's 10.
- There's a lot of people here.
- Desolate bench.
- And we need to find
a desolate, we need to go
to the most desolate place.
So we go to a desolate
place and I'm like okay,
this is cool, we're talking,
we're making observations
about the natural world.
We begin reading and then
as soon as we get down,
we read like two pages of our books
and then Shepherd's like,
I got to get some water.
And he's like, "Dad, will
you let me use the map
"to map to a water fountain
and then come back?"
- This is quite a park,
it's got its own map.
- And I was like, "Yeah, go for it."
Independence, I value that,
I'm a proponent of it.
He goes and then really the
idea wasn't to get water,
it was to go away and then
try to sneak up on me.
- Oh.
- He wanted, and so--
- He's got that gene.
- Yeah and so I'm sittin'--
- He got the waterman gene.
- There reading and I'm like--
- And just what I mean by
that is Rhett would do that
a lot to me as children.
- Where is,
where is Shepherd and I just kinda looked
and he was like 10 feet
behind me sneaking up on me.
He's like, "Aw, Dad!"
- (laughs) Just in the open?
- Yeah and then repeatedly he would leave
and then continue to sneak up on me.
(Link laughs)
And I caught him every time.
- Why you gotta catch him every time?
- And he was like--
- Gotta let him slip up once.
- Can you hear me?
(Link chuckles)
And I was like Shepherd,
I know where you're at at all times.
- Oh you're playing that.
- This is an opportunity
to make him feel like--
- It's a mind game.
- He's, he can't escape my watch.
- This is, this is,
this is givin' him the God complex.
- But then one of the
things, he's like, "Dad,
"there is a," he says,
"Look at these secret,"
in the little map, he was
like, "Find our hidden spot."
This is a large, multi-acre situation.
And he was like, "Find our hidden spots.
"There is a Fib-o-nakki,"
he couldn't say it,
he was like, "There is a
Fibonacci spiral of rock
"somewhere in this particular forest.
"Let's go find it."
- Mm-hmm.
That's cool.
- So we start looking
for the Fibonacci spiral,
and we didn't find it because
and ironically, we
probably should have done
a Fibonacci sequence
search pattern in order
to find the Fibonacci sequence
but we didn't do that
and we ran out of time,
we had to go pick up
Locke from school, anyway,
had an incredible time with Shepherd.
- Still undiscovered.
- He kept saying,
"I'm having so much fun."
- Aw, he kept saying that?
- "This is great.
"We're on an adventure."
- That's awesome.
- So I had a dadda, a
dada-gra, a dadditude?
No I didn't have a dadditude.
- Da-gratitude.
- Da-gratitude, but lemme say
just one little thing here.
- Say it.
- And I'm a little bit
embarrassed by this.
As someone who has an engineering degree
and has a lot of mathematical experience,
I could have picked out
a Fibonacci sequence
and if you gave me like four images,
I could have picked the one
that was a Fibonacci sequence
probably because like Brandon Tart
got it tattooed on his forearm.
And other people--
- It looks like a snail shell.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Right but I did not,
I could have not defined
what a Fibonacci sequence is.
And maybe you're in the same boat,
speaking of transitions to what
we're gonna talk about next.
But a Fibonacci sequence,
it's this fascinating thing.
In fact I actually think,
I actually ordered a book all about it
because I'm so fascinated by it
and I'd heard about it, people
talk about the golden ratio
but I was always like I don't
really know what that is
and I'm not gonna look it up.
But essentially Fibonacci
sequence is staring
from the number zero and
one and then continuing
in a sequence where the
next number is the sum
of the previous two numbers,
so you got zero and then one
and the next number is
zero plus one which is one,
the next number is one
plus one which is two.
And then two plus one which is three,
and then five and then eight and then 13
and then 21 and it continues
to add up like that.
And then, if you take, the
way you get that pattern
is if you take squares
that the length of the side
of the squares is the number
in the Fibonacci sequence
and you continue to connect
the corners of the squares
with the next biggest
one, it goes out like this
and it creates like a snail pattern.
- A spiral.
- A spiral that's very
recognizable pattern.
But then if you take any two numbers
in the Fibonacci sequence, the number
and then the number before it
and you divide the number before
it by the number after it,
you get this number called Phi which
we know Pi is a very
popular mathematical number
but Phi is like 1.618 something
and that's the--
- A constant.
- That's the golden ratio
and you see it all the time
in nature but also there's
many people who make sculptures
who were like, I want the
proportions of someone's face,
the proportions of the length
and the width of their face
to be Phi and you see it in,
Hank Green's got an old side
show video where he kinda,
in like three minutes kind of explains it
and talks about the patterns
and how you see these numbers
and the sequence show up
in nature all the time,
like flowers are usually
have petals of you know,
three, five, eight, 13, 21 and it shows up
in all these places in
nature and it seems like
some magic thing but really it's just,
it's the most efficient way to pack things
into different pattern,
anyway, super exciting.
- You should talk to
my wife more about that
'cause she's really into it.
You know she was a math major.
- She was.
- She was also told
as she was in high school
that whatever she did
with her boyfriend that her grandma up
in heaven was watching her.
- Was her grandma Fibonacci?
- No it was just kinda
like when you told Shepherd
that you're always watching
him so he stays in line.
- But I'm super excited
to talk to Shepherd
about it now because it's like--
- Now my wife's grandma watches me.
- Is watching us.
- Watching me.
No not us.
- She's sitting right here.
- No, whenever I'm with Christy.
- No whenever--
- She's watching us.
- No whenever you're
with the band Chicago.
That's--
- No I can--
- That's when she's watching you.
- My grandmas are still
living so they only watch me
when I'm there or video chat.
- But I'm legitimately, I'm like now--
- It's pretty crazy.
- I'm ready to go back
and A, find it.
- I'm talking about the sequence.
- Yeah but B, explain to Shepherd like,
this is actually this really cool concept
that shows up and I just felt,
you know what it made me
think, it made me think
that like I feel like
I've been missing out.
I was like why have I never,
I've heard people talk
about this and why have I
let it just wash over me?
41 years old, consider
myself pretty curious.
Why have I let the reality
of the Fibonacci sequence
to just wash over me
without ever just taking,
literally the 30 seconds
to look at the Wiki
to figure out what it is.
- I understand the sentiment
but I'll just counter that
by saying also don't let,
don't let that wash over you
but also don't let and
I'm sure you didn't,
let the fact that Shepherd told you
especially more than once that
he was having a good time.
- It was awesome.
- Because the dad,
I mean we've talked
about this a lot, like,
the goal of dadding we
operate under a lot of times
seems to be like I'm conducting this thing
and I want acknowledgement and so the fact
that you got that, that's a big deal.
And I actually think if you didn't,
you should tell him something
similar to what I told Lincoln
'cause I sat Lincoln down
at, when we were comin' back
from our ride, we're almost
done, we sat down on the rocks
and finished our water bottles and I said,
I told Lincoln what I
just told you, I was like,
you know when we first starting riding,
you were riding ahead
of me, I was thinking
this is like a dream come true for me.
I've been thinking about
us being able to ride
mountain bikes together
for months and you know,
a lot of logistics that had to line up
and this is very special,
and I just said that.
And then we took a picture
and I left it at that.
I wasn't asking for a response or anything
but the fact that Shepherd did
that, saying something like,
you know, when you said you
were having a great time,
that made me feel like I just discovered
the Fibonacci sequence.
(Rhett chuckles)
- Right.
- That's what it's all about, man.
- Also rabbits.
- That's the boat
you wanna get in.
- Also rabbits mate
in Fibonacci numbers.
I'm gonna teach him about that.
- Mate or reproduce?
- Well the results of mating.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna teach him
about sex with Fibonacci.
- We're gonna get into boats in a second.
But first, we're gonna talk about merch.
- I've got some merch on,
you've got some merch on.
We actually have the same Happy Chomper.
I've got the Happy Chomper
on the striped black
and white tee, Link has the Happy Chomper
on the handkerchief.
- I actually forgot this was merch.
I'm just now, I thought you
would have already called me out
on this but--
- Well you've been,
I saw you made a choice in Nashville
that you were gonna be a
guy who wears handkerchiefs
around your neck--
(Link chuckles)
Like some sort of outlaw,
I mean that's cool, I mean,
I was like you know what--
- At least I like
that interpretation, the
outlaw interpretation.
Bandana, what did he call it?
Handkerchief, yeah it's a bandana.
- Well I would use it as a handkerchief.
I would blow my nose into it.
- I do, I am fully
prepared to defend myself
but you never went for
it, so yeah, be like me,
wear this--
- Do you use it as a--
- Everything.
- Like a way to like
not get germs?
- I wipe everything with it.
- No I'm saying like you
can pull it up over your,
you can do like the people do in--
- Bandits, like a bandit.
- In the airports.
- Yeah like a bandit at
the airport yeah which is
totally cool.
- Or like that rapper,
what's the rapper?
- Tupac?
- No.
- I don't wear it like Tupac.
- The guy that's popular
now that wears the thing
over his face all the time.
- Oh I know who you're talking about
but I don't know his name.
Get your handkerchief on.
- Lil' something.
- Your bandana.
Mythical.store, get all types of stuff.
We're just trying to keep
you happy and surprised
and reppin' your boys.
- Okay boats.
So Link, you apparently have
a list of different types
of boats.
- Yeah I assembled a list
and then of every type
of boat in existence
and then I uploaded it to a
brand spankin' new Wiki page
called list of boat types.
- That's very thoughtful of you.
- This is entirely my work.
In alphabetical order.
So here's the deal.
- Good gracious there's a lot of boats.
- As I read through, I'm
not gonna read 'em all
but I'm just thinking dear Ear Biscuiteer,
maybe one of these boats
will resonate with you
so that you'll be able
to answer this question
and this is a good
conversation for you to have
with people that you
wanna get to know better.
Like say you're on a
third date, you're like,
"Hey baby, what kinda boat would you be
"if you were a boat?"
- This is a good, I mean
I think this is first
or second date material,
those kinda of questions,
those kinds of introspective
questions, the third date--
- I think it's a little
forced for a first date.
It's kinda weird unless
you are a therapist.
- I mean I'm a proponent of getting into--
- Get weird early?
- To those kinds
of conversations because here's the thing,
obviously I'm not in the dating pool.
If I were and I asked
that question to someone
and they were like (sighing),
I don't know.
- Dump 'em.
- I'd be like okay there's
not gonna be a second date.
- It's over, yeah you're right.
That's a good test.
- I can't stand that kind
of answer.
- All right so--
- I want somebody to have a
frickin' answer for something.
- All right that's good, so
this is a first date question.
You're right.
- Yeah.
- Hey if you could be a boat--
- This is how you
weed somebody out.
- What kinda boat would you,
if you could be a weed, what
kinda weed would you be?
- If they say I don't know and that's it,
if they say, "I don't know,
"well what kinda boats are
there," well okay that's fine.
- Yeah that's fine.
- But if they say
I don't know and then essentially saying
I don't wanna talk about this.
- If they poo poo the question.
- I mean I'm not gonna
go on a second date.
- Right, you can't poo poo
fun, esoteric questions
on a first date.
- And if they say the wrong
kind of boat there's not gonna
be a second date. (chuckles)
- Yeah you learn a lot.
Air boat, auxiliary ship, banana boat,
brig, bass boat.
I'm like a bass boat,
and you can't just say,
'cause I'm a redneck, no,
'cause I'm a fisherman, no.
- It's the functionality of the boat.
- I'm flat.
I'm shallow, bass boats are shallow.
- Oh really, you're getting
in, oh you're doing--
- So if you wanna say well I'm shallow
so I'm a bass boat, I've got,
I don't know, what else
would it mean about you
if you're a bass boat?
- Limited capacity.
I think first of all--
- Yeah?
- I think you should go
through the boat types
because I think the way that you--
- Canoe.
- Interpret the boats,
like you just said shallow--
- It's up to you.
- That's your thing.
For me I wasn't--
- I'm not shallow.
- Thinking in terms of
shallowness but you can bring,
I think that's the point of the question.
- There's no wrong answer.
- Professor Punch, if she were here,
she would be able to tell
us, but I think it's just,
it is what you make it.
- I wish she worked for us.
- Maybe that's how it
works, once you leave,
your parents come and work for us.
(Link chuckles)
- Canoe.
- Uh-huh.
- Chundan vallam.
- Not familiar.
- Crash rescue boat.
This is somebody who likes to swoop in
and save the day or
whenever they're needed.
- Yeah.
- You know they're there.
I'm not reading every single
boat that I wrote on this Wiki,
just whichever hits me.
A dinghy.
(Rhett softly chuckles)
Let's see, ferry.
So again this is more
of like a facilitator--
- Yeah, right.
- Somebody who likes to help
people get from point A to point B
and that could be emotionally,
it could me metaphysically,
it could be physically if
you're like a bus driver.
- And that would be someone
who was, in my interpretation,
stuck in a pattern of only helping people
because a ferry just goes back and forth,
back and forth.
- So on a first date--
- Like a codependency kinda thing.
- Your date's like, "I think I'm a ferry
"because I'm stuck in a
rut of helping people."
- Yeah I'd be like, ah,
no second date for you.
Are you a dinghy?
(both chuckle)
- Friendship sloop.
- Okay well I didn't know that was a boat.
But I'm definitely that.
- Garbage scow.
I think I know what that is.
It's a boat that carries
garbage, garbage scow.
- Uh-huh.
- Hydrofoil, ooh this is
technologically advanced.
It reaches a speed and then
it floats above the water.
Well not floats, it ascends.
So this is like, I don't
know what kinda person
that would be, maybe if you're like,
if your head's always in the clouds.
I'm stretching here.
- I think that's, I think
a hydrofoil might be
a little bit of a show-off.
- Oh, yeah.
♪ Here I am up above the water ♪
- You just can't, you can't
settle for just floating.
You've gotta levitate.
- You always gotta be movin' too.
- Inflatable boat.
- Oh, mm-hmm.
Reliant upon the hot air of other people.
- Oh. (chuckles)
I think that's you, man.
I just--
- I've got all my own hot air.
- I blow a lot of smoke, you
just, you inflate with it.
Actually you blow a lot,
maybe I'm the inflatable boat
'cause you blowin' smoke all the time.
I'm talkin' BS here, man.
- Blowin' smoke,
no I'm--
- Blowin' smoke up a skirt.
- Full of hot air might be
which is still the same thing.
Okay keep going 'cause we--
- Air bag, man.
- We gotta talk about these.
- Kayak, jet boat.
Life boat, long boat, log boat.
I'm skipping one that's
gonna be my answer for later.
- Really, okay, I'm not looking.
- Motorboat.
Naval ship, like a big battleship.
If you're like, if you're combatant.
There's a boat called an
optimist which is kinda cheaty.
If you're like oh well I
like to think of myself
as a, if I'm a boat, I'm an optimist.
That ain't a boat.
- Yeah.
No second date.
- You're short circuiting the exercise.
Actually I'm not, optimist is a boat
and it's--
- It's a dinghy.
- Also known as the bath tub,
it's a small single-handed sailing dinghy.
- Yeah.
- What else we got?
- The optimist is an optimistic way
to call yourself a dinghy.
- Oh, P, we've got patrol boat.
Pirogue or pleasure barge which
is how my wife thinks of me.
(chuckles)
When your grandma's not looking.
- Oh gosh, your grandma's always looking.
- Pleasure craft, pontoon,
powerboat.
I don't know what a punt
is, it's a type of--
- Oh I know what a punt
is because I'm looking
at doing that when I'm in England.
It's like a canoe basically, a rowboat
and then you stand in
it with a large stick
and propel yourself along a creek.
- Oh really so--
- You can go punting
in England.
- So instead of rowing,
you're pushing off the bottom.
- Mm-hmm, well--
- Okay.
- I looked at one picture and
that was my interpretation.
- R, we got a river boat.
Oh you got the big wheel in the back.
- Steam boat.
- Rodney boat which if
your name is Rodney,
that's also kind of
short-circuiting the exercise here.
Schooner, sea kayak.
Ship's tender, skiff,
skipjack, sloop.
♪ Come on Sloop John B ♪
Summarine.
I don't consider, is a summarine a boat?
- How do you say it?
- A summarine.
- Where's the B?
- It's under water. (chuckles)
- I was like is this a
boat that I've never--
- You ever tried to talk underwater?
- Summarine.
- Try to say words
with Bs underwater, you won't get far.
- You mean a submarine?
Yeah I've heard of that and
when it's on the surface,
it's a boat.
- If you saw a submarine
out there floating,
would you say, hey look at that boat?
- Well they called the
German submarines U-boats
and that was a boat.
I think it's a boat, it floats.
- Torpedo boat,
trawler, tugboat.
Tugboat, I mean that's a--
- Always helpin' people in a jam.
- I feel like I'm that around you a lot.
Come on, let's do it.
Let's get going man, no,
I don't feel that way.
I feel like I might need to be tugged.
- Oh. (laughs)
- What?
What you laughin' at?
Like creatively.
- Your grandmother-in-law
is watching, man.
- I'm just sayin'. (chuckles)
Like sometimes I'm not motivated at work,
just give me a tug.
- I know you didn't mean
that as an innuendo.
I know that you did not.
No, he did not mean it.
- The only boat term--
- He did not mean it.
- Under V is
Very Slender Vessel.
- Okay well dang that's
what I picked for myself.
(Link laughs)
- Well what are we doing here?
I think we should devote an entire podcast
to just reading Wikipedia lists.
- Yeah that'd be fun.
- And riffing on it,
and the only one for Z is Zille,
Zille.
- Zille.
- Okay so what do you
wanna do at this point?
Do you want, you wanna tell
me what you think I am?
And then I'll tell you
what I think you are.
- Yeah and then we'll go into the thing.
- Okay.
Go first.
- Well--
- I'm not gonna be offended by anything.
- Well first of all--
- I'm an open,
I have an open heart.
- Let me say a couple things, and just--
- You don't have to apologize.
- In laying the runway for this.
I didn't think about
this a lot. (chuckles)
- Okay.
- No actually what I learned
pretty quickly is that if
you imagine a boat type,
almost like a horoscope, you
can pretty quickly find a way
to make it match a person.
- Uh-huh.
- But I think I got
something that I think is--
- Well like a Jet Ski and a pontoon boat
are so different and they, and those--
- Okay, this is actually
remarkable that you said,
you said both of those.
- Okay.
- It's remarkable that we
haven't talked about this at all
and you just said those two things.
Here's what I would say--
- I am pretty remarkable.
Thank you.
- I think that someone who
doesn't know you well--
- Okay.
- And maybe who just
watches you on the internet
might be like Link's a Jet Ski, man.
- (chuckles) A Jet Ski, yeah, okay.
- But I actually think
you're a pontoon boat.
(both laugh)
- Really?
- Yeah, that's--
- That's what you were thinking?
- It's hilarious that you mentioned that.
I was thinking that
you were a pontoon boat
and here, let me explain why.
- Those are like polar opposites.
- You might be like, Link's a Jet Ski,
you never know what,
he's nimble, he's quick,
you never know where he's
gonna be, and boom he's there
and boom he's there and
he's a little flashy.
- He's always squirting
a tiny stream of water
directly into the air.
- Right, exactly.
- They all do that right?
WaveRunners and whatnot.
- But I think that that's actually...
The reason I don't think you're a Jet Ski
is because Jet Skis change
course very quickly.
You never know where they're going to be.
They're constantly changing
direction, changing course.
- You'll change course and
then it'll take a right
and you won't.
- Right.
And that is not your personality at all.
- Mm-mm.
- You're much more grounded than
I think most people understand.
- I'm a soil man.
- Now let me say a couple
things about a pontoon boat
that I think apply to you.
Pontoon boats, they exist,
they exist so people can have a good time.
- Oh.
At your service.
- What is, I mean, think about it.
You got a pontoon boat,
it's like no one looks
at a pontoon boat and is like,
if people look at a pontoon
boat and they're like,
well, we're gonna have a
good time on that boat.
- Yeah.
- The purpose of that boat--
- Slowly.
- Is to get on the boat and have a party.
- We're gonna slowly have a good time.
- And I think a lot of people
can be accommodated by that.
There's a few things
also about a pontoon boat
and that it's actually remarkably stable.
However--
- It's got those two big
barrels underneath it.
- However, when and it
happens every so often
and you hear it on the news.
- Yeah?
- When there is
a pontoon boat accident--
- What?
- It's bad.
- Oh gosh.
- And the, it isn't like a
sailboat that you knock it down
and then it comes back,
a pontoon boat goes under
and everyone dies. (laughs)
- What does that mean about me?
I don't know what you're saying.
You're saying if something happened to me,
a lot of people would die?
- No no I am saying that you are,
you're actually, you're way
more flexible than you were
when we were kids.
But and I actually think
that this point in your life,
you might actually be more
flexible than the average person.
- Are you about to take credit for that?
- No, but I do think being
married for a long period
of time and also being
in a close friendship,
business partnership--
- Absolutely, yeah--
- For a long time.
- Definitely.
- Makes people flexible and so,
but you, like a pontoon boat,
is typically, it's on a lake.
You know what I'm saying,
it's like, I'm on a lake
and I am, this is where the fun is at
and I am happy to be here
and you could potentially,
I could turn on the motor
and I could get out there into the river
and go into the ocean.
But you're gonna have to--
- Not really.
- You're gonna have to
convince me to do that.
- But practically speaking,
a pontoon boat, its home is a territory.
It's typically a lake.
- You know--
- You can take 'em on
a sound or something.
- You know what makes you--
- You're not gonna go out onto the surf.
- And I'm not, and again,
this isn't a perfect analogy,
because I'm also not saying
that you're not adventurous.
But your general disposition
tends to be like,
you know what, if I can
stay at home this weekend
and clean my garage,
that's what I'm gonna do.
- I don't wanna react too much because
I have a different answer but
there is a lot of overlap.
And so I'd like to come
back to the pontoon boat
and see how it works with what I think,
what my answer for myself is.
- Okay.
- I think my answer for you
is the answer that you have
in your own brain for yourself right now.
- Okay.
- I think that you are
thinking and I too am thinking
of you as a sailboat.
- Mm.
- Now I think first of all, just 'cause
whenever you are thinking about boats,
I think the first thing you're gonna think
about is a sailboat.
You have this imagined
aspirational love affair
with the idea of sailing.
- True.
- We've talked about this.
- Right.
- You may have even, we may
have even established it
as a what you call a layer
and I call a phase which
we have discussed at length
at an earlier Ear Biscuit
that you can go back
and listen to if you want to.
I mean,
if you pass a sailing book,
you're gonna pick it up,
if you pass a sailing channel on YouTube,
you're gonna watch it.
- True.
- So I think that's the
first thing you thought
and then you're motivated
to make that describe you
because again like you said
it could describe anything.
- Interesting.
- But then if I'm gonna, I
actually think this could work
because a sailboat is, you think of like,
adventurous, new thing.
I think...
There's like, you have to put in the work
when you're sailing.
You just can't lay back and troll around.
You can't just crank it up and steer.
That's my understanding.
There's a sail involved.
- Right.
- A lot of work and a lot of research.
The fact that you would
research the Fibonacci sequence
and then be angry at yourself
that you hadn't done it before now.
You felt the need to state publicly
that you're embarrassed by that,
is I think this dynamic
of, you wanna be able to,
okay, being an accomplished
sailor requires something.
I think I'm, by the way I think
I'm just making an argument
for why you wanna be a sailor,
not what your personality is.
- Right, it's about the boat, man.
- Someone who sails needs
to put in a lot of work
and then the fruits of that labor is
that they can experience something new.
And I do think that the work
that you put into things
is always motivated by
experiencing something new.
And I think it's
well-documented that the work
that I put into things is
to make something better
or to make a situation better
or to make the situation,
in contrast, more secure, more right.
- Right.
- Yours is to,
to achieve or experience something new.
So sailing is like what's the next harbor?
- Right.
- What's the next,
what's the next adventure,
what's around the next peninsula?
So and there's also a lot of wood.
You like wood.
- Yeah I got wood.
- You like it.
A lot of wood in a sailboat.
So again, I'm making more of an argument
that you really like
sailboats but I do think
that it could apply
and I think that's what
you're gonna build on when you say
that your answer is a sailboat.
- Okay, so do you want
to respond to what I said
about you first?
- I kinda wanna,
I kinda wanna just go with it.
Just say sailboat.
- Okay.
- Am I right?
- You're not, you're half right.
Here's why you're half right.
- What's half a sailboat?
- A boat that is sinking.
(chuckles playfully)
- Oh gosh.
- My first thought was sailboat.
- Of course, yeah, so
I'm right about that.
- And then upon further review,
I thought I want to be a sailboat,
but I actually don't
think that I quite am.
- Mm-hmm.
- Now let me explain.
So what you said about,
you know, and I tend
to embrace new adventure, travel,
I'm using this as an analogy
like move into something new
and unknown and going through unknown,
potentially uncharted
dangerous waters to get there,
like that's my life blood,
like I absolutely love that.
- And it implies achievement.
That's the other part.
- Yeah.
- Which I think drives you.
- And that is, yeah, I'm, you
know, we've talked about it.
We haven't done the podcast yet
but I am an Enneagram three.
And so I'm a performer, I'm an achiever,
and I'm largely driven by accomplishment
to my benefit and to my demise at times.
But the one thing that I
don't think applies to me
with the sailboat is that a sailboat is...
Well and I also tend to think,
I think of myself as pretty resilient,
like being able to right
myself and that kind of thing,
in storms and that kinda thing.
But a sailboat is very reliant,
by definition it is not self-propelled.
It is, you gotta get, the
wind's gotta come along.
And I actually think that I'm actually
a little bit less
resilient than a sailboat
and I'm significantly more
self-propelled than a sailboat.
I actually think I'm a,
I'm gonna use the qualifier
cheap yacht. (chuckles)
And this is why I say that.
So in some ways, like a
yacht, like a powerboat
that's made to go long distances.
So embraces adventure.
It can get you to the same
places that a sailboat can,
not quite as sure of a thing as a sailboat
because again, you're
under your own power.
Not quite, it doesn't
have the same ability
to right itself.
Yachts seem to be a
little bit depending on,
and I say cheap because you know you go
to like a seaside town
and you go to the harbor
and you see everybody's got their boats
and they've got their yachts
and there's big yachts,
there's little yachts,
there's yachts in between
and you've got like the CEO
yacht which is this really
expensive, magnificent
yacht that's got like
a helicopter pad on it.
I'm not that, I'm like the guy who just
got together money and went
in debt to get this boat
that kinda, it looks like it could belong
in a harbor but it's posing a little bit.
- Okay.
- But I think that the
self-propelled nature of it--
- So you're a
self-reliant poser.
- Well just because,
you know, and it's funny
because it's interesting,
you talked about your kids
and I look at my kids
and you see qualities
from yourself in your kids and
qualities from your partner
in your kids.
And like, Locke is really just
self-motivated, right, like
once he got in his mind
that he wanted to play
basketball or make good grades
or, he's learning a language in school
and he's learning a language on his own
and he's like, 'cause
learning a language is like
so good for your brain.
I hear myself--
- Yeah.
- When he goes into these
explanations but it's almost like
it's intensified 'cause Jessie's
also very self-motivated
so it's almost like it's
very intensified in him
and you kinda like
reflect back on yourself,
but and again I think
that I don't always think
this is a good thing, I
think that like you said,
I shouldn't feel any
shame or embarrassment,
embarrassment for not knowing
what the Fibonacci numbers are
but I have a dual
motivation for knowing that.
It's part a genuine interest
and a genuine curiosity
because it's like this
is a reality that exists
in our universe that is
this fundamental thing
that can be observed in
all these different ways
and it's like, it feels significant
and it feels like I'd be missing out
if I didn't understand it.
But then the other half is,
I wanna be able to talk about it.
I wanna be able to tell someone about it
so that I will seem smart.
You know, I have to fight
against that tendency.
- Kinda like when a
cheap yacht pulls up next
to like a pontoon.
- Exactly, exactly.
- It starts filling his ear full of stuff.
- Well and that's the constant
battle of the Enneagram three
is there's a lot of
good that come come from
that personality but then
you can actually get very
caught up in your own stuff, you know,
and believe your own, what is the phrase?
Smell your own, or something.
What is it?
- I never heard that.
I've done it but I've never heard it.
- You know what I'm saying.
So anyway I think I'm a cheap yacht.
- Cheap yacht because
you're self-motivated
and you still like to go a lot of places.
- And I suffer from imposter syndrome,
I think that's where
the cheap yacht comes in
is that I do, we do a
lot of different things,
we have the privilege of doing
a lot of different things.
We talked about it a little
bit, like playing at the Ryman,
like there's many times
that we get to do things
and I suffer from heavy
doses of imposter syndrome
where I'm like I shouldn't be here,
like I'm not, I'm just a dude
that can write a funny song
and convince people that
I've got some talent.
- We got way too many
balls jokes to be at this--
- Right.
Yeah so I think that's where
the cheap part comes in.
- The high church of country music.
- Yeah.
- That's what I call it,
the high church of country music,
that's not what it's actually called.
What's it called?
- The mother church.
(sighs) Okay.
Who am I to critique that, you know,
there's no wrong answers.
- Right, yeah.
- That's cool insight that
if we were on our first date,
I'd be like oh, no second date here.
(Rhett chuckles)
Okay.
Shall I talk about--
- You shall.
- My boat.
Well, you know I did think of, well,
the backdrop to my
thought process is Christy
and I were talking about one
of the contributing factors
to the health of our marriage 19 years in
and I was like, you know,
I just think for us,
the compatibility, like the
core compatibility that we had,
it's like we've changed a lot, and yeah,
we've changed together
even though at every turn,
you don't have to, you know.
Who knows how, you can't control exactly
the person you become.
We're very fortunate that we've changed
in a parallel path.
- Mm-hmm.
- But I think a lot of it has to do with
that core compatibility
which I kinda boil down to
we both really place a high
value on comfort and security.
Like there's a, and so
it motivates us so much
that yeah you're exactly right,
when I say, when I'm given
an opportunity of like,
you wanna travel anywhere
on the globe next weekend.
Or you wanna just stay at
home and re-clean your garage.
(Rhett snorts)
And that's not an easy decision.
I'm not saying it's
automatic but I'm saying
that's a difficult
decision for me and Christy
and it's like that could
be a big source of conflict
if somebody never wants
to re-clean their garage.
- Right.
- So we have like,
we got the same instinct when it comes
to those things and so,
that conversation is
kinda coloring my boatage
and so yeah I definitely
thought about a pontoon boat
because I was thinking about it,
Jet Ski versus a pontoon
boat and how Jet Ski's like
all about fun!
But a pontoon boat is still
about, there's still fun.
- Yeah.
- It's a party boat.
But it's very, it's very,
it's a controlled fun.
There is a control element
to like I have a vision
for how I think things should be
and my motivation is
usually pretty pure in like,
oh I wanna have fun,
want people to have fun,
want people to enjoy
themselves, experience love.
Be themselves, that type of stuff.
And then I moved onto well,
I don't know if I'm a pontoon boat.
I think I might be, I place such a value
on things being like my space being nested
and like the way that I want it.
My home is such a haven to me.
I'm like I think I might be a houseboat.
- Mm, okay.
- And like I was kinda
curious because you know,
Jessie has such a vision
for how she wants your house
to look and I feel like it's much,
that's weighted much more towards her
and it is for me and Christy too, like,
she's very talented at
decorating and does our house
and stuff, and all that stuff.
But I'm very much involved in
everything because I want it
to be how I want it to be
from a practical standpoint.
Like I take so much joy in
knowing that everything's
where I want it to be
in the garage or like
our backyard works in this
way or I wanna be able
to sit here and see this while doing this
and listening to this
music and like put a lot
of work into that into my house.
So that's when I started to think
I could be a houseboat
but I think I'm a yacht.
(both laugh)
And I actually, I settled on,
in the exhale brief amount
of time that I thought about this,
I actually settled on,
and I ain't even talking
about like a two-bit yacht,
we both have said yachts for ourselves.
My answer is freakin' yacht.
And I went all the way
to like helicopter pad
and everything because
I place an over-emphasis
on my environment being
exactly how I want it to be
and as luxurious as it could be. (laughs)
Like I want my life to be engineered,
not from a pleasure alone
but for my comfort
and security, you know,
so that's when I thought
about a yacht, I guess, but
maybe it's a pontoon yacht.
I do like to go places and I
like to experience adventure
but it has to be much more on my terms
than I think yours would be.
I didn't think about like being,
am I self-motivated, that didn't enter
in my equation or anything.
- I can see that.
- Comfort and security.
I want a yacht with a chef and like--
- Well maybe you're like a yacht--
- A security detail.
- You're a yacht on like
the Great Lakes.
You know what I'm saying, the Great Lakes,
you can't see the other side.
- Are there yachts on the Great Lakes?
- Heck yeah.
You see how big they are?
Look at a map, man.
They're massive.
- Yeah, I've just never
looked at the Great Lakes.
- You can get caught in the
squall on the Great Lakes too.
- Chicago, I've seen the
Great Lake at Chicago.
- Yeah I don't--
- Open the door and it just blasts.
- And also a yacht is a pretty broad,
incidentally, very broad term.
I mean like I don't know
what the technical definition
of it is but it does, it is
one of the more flexible terms
for boats so it doesn't surprise me that
for different reasons we ended up there.
I mean I think that...
(sighs)
- I could probably just go
back to settling on houseboat
'cause I think that does,
I've never been on a houseboat
but I imagine--
- I spent an evening on one.
- Really?
- A weekend.
- Well I imagine them being,
if you're gonna live there,
they better be how you
wanted them to be, you know?
- Yeah.
- As opposed to, I can endure this for,
until we get to, if we
get through the squall
and I can get back to the mainland.
- It's interesting and
this is another show
I wanna do, I was talking
to you about this.
'Cause you talk about
making these decisions
and getting things the way that you want.
And the way that I relate
to that, because we're also,
we're basically redoing our homes,
similar amounts of change, like,
you guys have done more already but like,
I'm redoing my whole backyard this summer.
And we've done, there's a bathroom inside,
you guys just finished a bathroom.
There's renovations, we redid
our kitchen, that kinda thing.
And my involvement is very much like
aesthetically, I care,
but I also know that
if Jessie narrows it down to five
different options for tile--
- They're all gonna be awesome.
- They're all gonna be great, so it's like
she's showing them to me,
they've already gotten
through so many levels of
discretion that I'm just like,
just make the decision,
like, I'm not particular.
I want it to be cool and
I want it to look good
but I know that it will be if you do it
and so I'm not particular
so I'm not gonna,
what I do is I say I care about
like a few practical things,
not to the level of detail,
anywhere close to the level
of detail that you do but I'm like okay,
where's the grill gonna go?
Okay I'm gonna go out
there, this is important,
I'm gonna use this thing, I'm
gonna be the man at the grill.
I wanna think about what
kinda grill it's gonna be
and I'll get really excited
about the specific type
of grill and where it is
but then it's not gonna
go much deeper than that.
And I think about, I think,
oh, what I wanted to say is that
the episode that I wanted to do was,
is we're both in the market
to get a new vehicle.
- You can get a boat that
drives on land I think.
- And I'm fascinated with
differences in the way
that we make that decision.
- Oh.
- So you're talking about
surrounding yourself
with luxury and getting
things the way you want,
but the decision to get a
new car has been one that has
(chuckles), I mean, I'm
not gonna get into it
because I think there's
a whole episode there.
- Okay well we can save that.
- But it's interesting because--
- So we gonna have a boat
episode and a car episode?
- Well but at least--
- The transportation series--
- But at least--
- Ear Biscuits.
- The boat episode is
not like what kinda boat
am I gonna buy 'cause that's
like next level douche.
- Yeah, okay.
- But if it's just like what
kinda car am I gonna buy?
- Which kinda private
plane am I going to--
- We could get into some
douchiness in that conversation
but I just, I think it's,
again, it's very revealing
about the nature of our personalities
and the way that we make decisions
about those kinds of things.
But the way that we both ended
up kinda landing on yacht.
(chuckles)
- That's funny, I think
that means that we can,
we should go in on a yacht.
- Oh.
- With I guess like 100 other people.
How many people, I mean--
- A yacht share?
- Yeah can you do that?
I'm much more interested
in gettin' a yacht
than I am about more
introspection at this point.
So let's continue our
own conversation that way
but I'll open it up,
#EarBiscuits, let us know
what boat you think you are.
And if you're on a first date
and you're listening to this,
don't listen to us during the first date.
I mean--
- Yeah that would be weird.
- But I do recommend that you recommend us
to anyone you're dating.
- But if somebody--
- And listen separately
so we get twice the listens.
- If somebody asks you
to listen to a podcast
on the first date, that is a red flag.
Even if it's this one.
- Yeah, but let's make
an exception for ours.
- Maybe a portion of a podcast.
- Any other podcast.
- But a podcast is like
typically like an hour of just listening
to other people talk.
- How's that different
than going to a movie?
All right let's save that too.
We got another whole
episode about first dates.
- You shouldn't go to a
movie on the first date.
That's a red flag.
- There you go.
- What you gonna learn about
somebody sittin' next to 'em
looking at a screen?
Nothing.
- If you watch them.
- I mean if you watch
the movie and you talk about it.
I don't know, man.
- Yeah you're, that's a hot
take, that's harsh take.
- Okay.
- #EarBiscuits, let us know
what kind of boat you are and why
or what kinda boat someone you're dating
said they were and why.
Let's make a recommendation,
is it my turn?
- Yep.
- I gotta go back to music
because here's the thing.
Nothing is more exhilarating than,
well probably is, I
gotta back track already
but I love the exhilaration associated
with discovering an artist
and then realizing they got
a whole back log of material.
So it's not like the
Horses in the Back guy.
You look at him on Spotify
and that's the only song
he's got, well, you got the
remix with Billy Ray Cyrus.
- Yeah, pretty limited.
- I'm not recommending that.
I'm not panning it either though.
But when you look on Spotify,
you find something somewhere
and then you're like whoa, there's albums.
Like I could deep dive.
Let's do it.
And then when you like the
song and then you click over
to the Wiki because you
like knowing a little bit
about the backstory and you
realize that this artist
is described as a virtuoso violinist
who then is also well-known as a whistler.
- What?
- He's a virtuoso
violinist and a virtuostic,
virtuostistic?
- Mm-hmm.
- Whistler.
(whistles melodically)
- At the same time?
- Could be, yeah, he can
sing and play the violin
at the same time.
And he's got a number
of instrumental albums.
- How did you find--
- One is called Canyon
and one is called River
and I think at least
with the Canyon one, maybe with both,
he would take his violin and he would play
in that location.
- What's his name?
- In Utah,
I ain't tellin' you yet
man, I'm building it up.
- Oh.
- See you want it so bad.
(Rhett scoffs)
But you can't get it yet.
- Oh I wouldn't say
I want it that bad. (chuckles)
- And he takes his violin
and he does these looping
and layering parts and it's amazing.
But that's just instrumental stuff.
And then his brand new
album that just came out,
I'm like, this sounds like
the guy who Father John Misty
has been impersonating.
I mean he's got that sound.
So I'm just joking, I'm not,
I'm sorry Father John, I,
I'd like to be your friend, I'm
not saying you impersonate--
- So he sings as well?
- He sings.
- Oh it's not all whistling.
'Cause that would get old.
- Right.
So he is a lyricist and a
vocalist and a touring musician.
And his name is Andrew Bird.
Dude is awesome.
- Andrew Bird.
- Yeah, shout out to Andrew Bird.
Check out his song Sisyphus.
He's got a whistling part
in that and it's one thing
to hear the whistle but
then it's another thing
to watch him on his
Instagram perform it live
and he just effortlessly goes
into this immaculate whistle.
(chuckles)
- I'd give a lot to whistle,
well I can't whistle, man.
- You can't whistle at all.
- You can make yourself
an instrument at any time.
(whistles melodically)
I can hit like two notes.
- Too airy.
I can whistle like this too.
(both whistling)
- That's as high as I can get.
- That's a tongue whistle.
- I can go--
(chuckles)
(whistles softly)
- That sucks, man.
(whistles flatly)
- I'm like a teakettle.
You know what I'm sayin', I
got one, I got a limited range.
- Now I can't, you took away my whistle.
- Yeah.
- I can't do the fingers
in the mouth whistle.
That's a big dad play.
- Yeah.
- We gotta work on that.
So there it is, Andrew
Bird, check him out.
Shout out to the man with the whistle.
With the golden whistle.
- Okay.
- All right.
Let's start searching up some yachts, man.
Let's see how much it--
- Maybe we should just--
- I mean let's just rent a yacht.
- Maybe we should just go
on a pontoon boat first.
- Like Chase said he went to a wedding
this past weekend on a yacht.
- Well you remember I wanted
to have my birthday party
on a yacht and got the yacht rock band
and then I looked into the price.
- Yeah and that's an indication
you will not be purchasing a yacht.
(Rhett chuckles)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)